how has the landscape of crime changed
in this country the sorts of cases you
would see before you uh have we always
had as much knife crime as we seem to
have now has that grown in recent years
what is the situation
uh I don't know the statistics but I do
know my experience so I would have begun
uh going to the Old Bailey uh as a
barrister when I first came to the bar
as a baby Barrister if I was lucky
enough to be briefed as Junior Council
sitting behind a QC in a big case
um and if you walked along the corridors
of the Old Bailey where there are 18
courts you would have seen a few murders
quite a few murders but that have been
caught after court with armed robberies
with rapes with cases of a non-fatal
nature
you don't see that so much at the old
bayley anymore frankly you barely see it
at all nearly every courtroom for years
now will have been occupied with murders
um or a bit of terrorism
there are other things but essentially
that's what goes on there
um not necessarily murders let me
replace that with the word homicides
because there are different ways of
killing the people but that's what we do
and even the lowest level homicides even
and I don't want to downplay the gravity
of them but even something as
um
how do I put it without making it sound
as if it is less serious even something
like death by careless driving you've
got a death there uh that's what we do
there
but most of the courtrooms will be
dealing with death using weapons
and most of the weapons will be knives
and most of the defendants will be 25 or
under
and once I say that you will see
immediately what's been happening in our
society the rise of gangs the links
between gangs and drugs gangs and
violence
inter-gang violence
so um there has been to my mind and in
my experience
a sea change now I know that people will
produce statistics that um throw
different angles on that
but I think it is clear there has been a
change over the last
45 years since I became a barrister and
when did you start noticing this change
Wendy when did the change start
occurring for you
um
I have certainly seen it since I've been
a judge in 2007 but I think you could
probably go back a decade before that to
begin to see it the roots must have been
there before that they must have been
because these things don't drop down out
of a clear blue sky
but um
the carrying of knives has become
I hesitate to use the word but I will
endemic in some parts of our society and
it is not limited to those who belong to
gangs
but if those who belong to gangs are
carrying knives and creating a violent
situation for others to be living in
then the risk of the others carrying
knives in response is enormously
increased and when you saw these people
who were carrying knives and were
accused of murder
did they were there commonalities
between them did they have did they
share certain characteristics we've
already mentioned the age thing 25 and
under what type of people were there
um
well
um I don't want to sound like a bleeding
heart
um but I guess people that we as a
society didn't
sort out look after care enough about
recognize their problems
um
there are bad people there's no there's
no two ways about it there are there are
Wicked people
but if you asked me how many times I've
seen someone who in my judgment was
truly Wicked
not what they did was wicked but that
they themselves was were wickhamed in
the dock I could count them over nearly
half a century on the fingers of of my
hands
if you ask me how many people have done
really wicked things
the answer is I've seen thousands so the
question that maybe we should be asking
ourselves is
why people who are not essentially bad
do bad things and why they're doing it
at the age of 16 17 19
21. and they are certainly based on your
experience uh they were not doing it as
much 30 40 50 60 years ago so what do
you think it is that's causing uh this
increase
um
we have become
this may be entirely wrong but my sense
is we've become very short-termist at
least we've allowed our children to grow
up with a sense of being very
short-termist now if I put that in the
starkest terms
um
you don't see many gang members in their
40s 50s 60s and 70s and you laugh
because it is self-evident that you
don't
but what that means is when youngsters
devote themselves to that way of life
they're not looking into a future
they're not looking into a long-term
future
um a lot of them die a lot of them are
seriously harmed a lot of them die from
injuries a lot of them die from other
things associated with the lifestyle
particularly if they become addicted to
drugs
um
a lot of them
end up with seriously miserable
lives in their mid-30s once you're part
of a gang it's very difficult to
extricate yourself and lead a different
sort of Life once you've been to prison
and have a criminal record
put that the other way around once
you've got a criminal record whether or
not you've been to prison it's
extraordinarily difficult to work your
way back into society again and so um
we've got a whole bunch of youngsters
who are not
as school kids saying
where am I going with my life how am I
going to
um have a family have a career they're
doing something quite different
and if you see the sorts of
backgrounds and lives that they're
living
it's not that surprising
foreign